- Alright, heading back uptown
and DRock and I decided that
we don't need to film this one
meeting so DRock took notes
all day, what the hell
was interesting today? Go.
(upbeat music)
'Sup man?
Good to see you.
- Good to see you.
- [Gary] Morning, morning.
I remember them super well.
As a matter of fact is it
possible that my first laptop
computer came from your dad?
I'm almost positive that the
laptop that your dad got me
which had a CD-ROM which was
insane at the time was the
computer that I used was
to launch WineLibrary.com.
Is this where we're going?
- [DRock] Yeah, I think so.
- Actually, you know what?
Why don't you guys
introduce yourself?
I want to get this fixed.
This has been
happening all day long.
I'll be right back everybody.
- [Man] Hey Gary.
- [Gary] Hey guys.
- [Man 2] Hi there.
- [Man] What's up?
- I've been in like 10 meetings
in a row now where like either
it takes 10 minutes or they
can't even get to the
Apple TV/HDMI set up.
And now we're just told like,
Lindsay's like well my computer
doesn't work 'cause we haven't
updated yet this, that
and the other thing.
What's, couple quick questions.
What's going on and then,
two, can we get HDMI
cables in all these rooms.
It just seems like seriously
like I'm wasting 10, 15, 7,
9 minutes in every meeting.
- [Man] What room
are you in right now?
- Adventureland.
- [Man] Adventureland.
That room has known issues.
We're trying to get that fixed.
- So is there a room,--
- [Man 2] Cable specifically.
And then the AirPlay thing is
a separate issue based on the
version of the operating
system that people are on and--
- What's the punchline?
- [Man] We got to get
people updated better on--
- [Man 2] Anything before
El Capitan which was last year's
release, they need to
get up to El Capitan.
We have the means to do that
so it can take 20 minutes for
that to happen and
during the work day.
- So do you guys, is this more
on them not wanting to waste
their 20 minutes?
Do they, can they do it,
do you have to do it?
Like, what's, help me help you.
I can make them all do it.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- Like I can, you know I mean?
- [Man 2] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Help me help.
Here's what I would like,
here's what I would like,
let's do this.
Send me an email with your plan
but here's the bottom line,
I can make them all do so,
I will make them do it,
whatever they
have to do and then
I need you to address fast,
with no financial
thoughts in mind,
the rooms that
aren't working.
- [Man 2] Okay.
I'll do that.
- Cool?
- [Man 2] Cool.
When you think of it at my
level, we're losing more money?
Like I'm losing pitches.
- [Both] Yeah.
- Do you know what I mean?
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Man 2] For sure.
- I don't care what it takes.
I don't care what else is
going on, we're just losing.
So whether we need to buy it
and it needs approval, approved.
Whether it's you've got
something else, tell me what
that is and I'll tell you
that don't have to do that.
Now if you're like the security
of the whole company is online
then I'll say yes, do that.
You're like, help me help me
help you in the next 24 hours.
- [Man] Okay.
- Alright?
- [Man 2] Cool.
- The other thing,
I would have a full, that's it.
I would have full media intern.
For example, that same intern,
or two by the way, I mean again
if it's free or if they can get
credits or minimum wage there's
just a lot of people smart
enough to know that getting
close to you like that works.
- [Betty] Yeah.
- You know, the other thing
is one of them could be
booking podcasts for you.
I mean if you're doing
everything, you're dead.
Like I did it.
Two and a half years ago, I was
all by myself doing all that.
- [Betty] Really?
- [Gary] Yeah so...
- [Betty] That's how I feel.
- [Gary] Right so it's hard but
when other people are doing it
a lot more can be done.
It takes time to find the right
cadence but we created a service
for that but it's not gonna
be affordable for most people.
- [Betty] Right.
- [Gary] I want you to extract
the theses from it and
then go and execute it. Scale.
Scale and everybody thinks scale
is technology and that's what
everybody's talking about.
Scale comes in people.
Scale comes in people as well
and it's a version that has been
tried and true long before
the internet came along.
And so I think most of us are
grossly underestimating the
impact of another human
being on what they're trying to
accomplish and what you
could be doing for them.
We're all looking for the
algorithm and big data and the
tech and the app
that's going to scale it.
There's nothing that
scales the tried and true.
Do you understand?
If you're actually getting
engaged with your community,
there's no algorithm.
You can do that.
You think that works but it
doesn't because the essence
behind it isn't actually happening.
You can only scale so far.
The human part of it
is an absolute must.
Scale is a part of it.
Both, both matter.
- So my name is Jon Troutman.
I've worked with
Gary for seven years,
at VaynerMedia for about four.
I work really closely with him,
the leadership team kind of
supporting different special
projects and initiatives that
they're focused on.
Previously came from
the wine industry.
I worked with Gary a lot on his
personal brand and wine content
side of things at a small
wine social network and then
eventually worked with him in
Daily Grape which was his wine
app which frankly was
kind ahead of its time.
A lot of mobile video content
that people are now
watching right now.
And then from there
I kinda pivoted over
and came to VaynerMedia.
Think one of the biggest things
that I've come to realize as
we've grown so quickly is
that you can't be
hands-on with everything.
It's kinda the analogy that Gary
uses clouds and dirt and it's
knowing when to be really
hands-on and micromanage some
things versus like what are the
things that you should empower
and let leaders go out
and do on their own.
I think that's something that
I really learned a lot from him
over the years is like there
are certain things that you
definitely want to get your
hands dirty with and be super
involved with especially when
the stakes are high and there's
other things that like frankly
as you scale and grow business
that you got to allow
other people to kinda
take on and run with.
- [Zack] This is,
without a doubt,
10 of the most exciting
minutes of my life.
I've come here really just to
tell you about myself,
my hustle and my company.
I'm not asking you
to invest today.
I just want to get to know you.
- [Gary] Yeah.
Creating the context.
I believe in this the most.
I mean, believe in it the most
and believe you which is why,
get over here DRock, the 40,000
of you that do it every day and
wondering why he gets in either
I believe the person is smart
enough to play a 20 year
marathon or I think all the
people that say they're going to
buy me lunch and that's worth my
hour so I genuinely you which
is how we've got here in a world
where I only do this five,
ten, eight times a year.
- So my name is Zack Dixon.
I'm from New Orleans, born in
New Orleans, live there now.
Spent the last five
years in New York.
The last two
hustling on Players Lounge.
Love this.
And yeah, I reached
out to Gary in July
and I emailed him and I said
how many days in a row was
the subject line and then the
next line in the email box
body was would it take for me to
email you in a row before
I could get you to respond.
Then I emailed again on day two.
I told him a little
bit more about myself.
And then, I emailed him again
on day three and he responded.
- [Gary] Yeah, and by the way,
there are thousands of people
that are still doing it and
will never get the meeting.
- [Zack] Cool.
- There are thousands
of people doing that.
Perseverance is only
one part of the equation.
- [Zack] Yeah.
- Actually believing that that
person is playing a 40 year game
or it's a good
context creator--
- [Zack] Yeah.
- the key moment for
you in your career
because I can do that too
and so can a lot of other
people believe it or not,--
- [Zack] Yeah.
- is can you back that sizzle.
It's everything.
You know, I believe
you in that part.
We're sitting here.
- [Zack] Of course.
Of course.
- The next part
matters so fuckin' much.
And the number one
thing I'm gonna tell you,
the only thing I'm gonna
tell you because
I think you're
gonna figure it all
out you don't need me this, is
if you ever think that the steak
is not coming together properly,
over communicate to the people
that bought into your sizzle.
- [Zack] So you're saying
that if it's not gonna pan out,
- [Gary] Yeah, you got it.
If it's not pan out when you're
jamming with me and Strauss
and all these people,--
- [Zack] Yeah.
- we've all lost too.
- Be smart about how
you navigate that.
- [Zack] Yeah.
- Too many people are great to
get in the room, are destined to
actually win on their second
or third or fourth thing--
- [Zack] Yeah.
- when losing in the first
thing, they handle it so poorly
that they lose so
much of what they...
America, you see
where I'm going?
Yeah, America
hates the cover up.
(tape rewinding)
So DRock, you took notes
all day, what the hell was
interesting today? Go.
(light music)